you've discovered the flow arts and the
community around it and you can't help
but notice that well
it's pretty hot around here pun intended
might you find love with a fellow prop
spinner will you find heartache is it
even a good idea to date within the
scene
let's unpack some stuff here drex here
from drexfactor poi sharing with you the
love of poi spinning and flow arts to
benefit your body and brain and today i
want to talk about flow arts from the
lens of finding partners and lovers in
the community what can go wrong and what
can go right before we dive in i just
want to give a quick shout out to the
friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing businesses and what they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
i've got down in the description of this
video and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
machinski and becca beckham thank you
all so very much for your support from
my work and my mission
the flow arts community can be a fun
place to be the people are friendly open
and creative and sometimes being in that
community can make you feel like you're
understood in a way that happens nowhere
else so it's hardly surprising that
people take a look around and think hey
this community might not be a bad place
to look for potential romantic or sexual
partners but is that actually a good
idea what are the benefits what are the
potential pitfalls is dating in the flow
arts more likely to result in happily
ever after or listening to taylor swift
songs on repeat as you work your way
through a quart of ice cream not that i
would know the short answer from my
perspective yes but let's get into why
this is a complicated question let alone
a complicated answer if you're new here
please leave a like comment and
subscribe i post videos on poi spinning
and flow arts so make sure you get
notified every time i upload a new one
so i'm going to say up front that the
views i'm expressing here are going to
be based upon a mixture of my own
personal experiences as well as those of
people that i know and that i've seen
shared online
in my 15-year career in the flow arts i
have both dated people within the scene
as well as outside of it and it's
definitely given me an interesting
sample set to work with and before you
ask no i am not going to be sharing any
personal details about me or anyone else
here
i'm not putting anyone on blast if you
want t on relationship drama in the flow
arts there's a facebook group for that
and we also have to acknowledge the
obvious here which is that my
perspective is that of a cis-hat
monogamous white man in the flow arts
scene
and that inevitably filters the
experiences that i have in it
i'm going to do my best here to
incorporate other views and experiences
outside of my own but i also have no
shortage of blind spots so
if i'm wearing that privilege in a way
that's tainting the information that i'm
sharing please do not hesitate to sound
off about what i'm missing in the
comments with all that said let's first
talk about some of the positives about
dating within the flow art scene from
the jump we have to point out the
obvious it is great having one or more
partners with whom you share a hobby or
leisure activity this isn't restricted
to the flow arts and whether it's biking
cooking or benjing netflix shows having
things that you can do with your partner
or partners is part of what makes
relationships work and because flow and
fire arts are so incredibly niche it can
sometimes be a challenge to bridge the
gaps with somebody who is either
adjacent to it or not involved in it at
all
i've definitely dated people that didn't
understand my commitment to the flow
arts and over time it became a wedge
that was more and more difficult to try
and work through dating another flow
artist means that you're with somebody
who not only supports your hobby but is
right there with you in it going to spin
jams and flow festivals and maybe even
practicing with you
it means time spent in flow is not time
spent apart and that can be huge second
it can be super awesome to do flow arts
collaborations with somebody
romantically or sexually involved with
doing that work together can deepen the
relationship and result in great work
that neither or none of you were capable
of on your own and there are so many
potential collaboration opportunities
too
shooting videos together building props
together choreographing performances
together running events together
these really are opportunities to create
things that are more than the sum of
their parts plus which working on
projects together isn't just an
opportunity to create a cool outcome but
also to workshop things like navigating
compromises and conflicts in a space
that can be a great testing ground for
developing new techniques without
putting the relationship itself at risk
finally what about the shared values of
flow artists we tend to have a pretty
unique set of values perspectives and
world views that certainly make it seem
like dating one or more other flow
artists makes it more likely that you'll
connect with somebody who shares your
values and life goals but this one's
actually just a little bit complicated
because i think this is a major
motivation a lot of people have in
dating within the scene
but it's also a textbook example of a
really specific cognitive bias that
human beings employ now stick with me
here for a second but there's actually a
really famous psychology problem that
goes like this
there's a young woman named linda linda
is 31 years old single outspoken and
very bright she majored in philosophy
and as a student she was deeply
concerned with issues of discrimination
and social justice and also participated
in anti-nuclear demonstrations is it
more likely that linda is a a bank
teller or b a bank teller and a feminist
if you want to you can pause this video
for a second to think on it i'll give
you the answer in just a moment
so this one can actually be really
really hard for people to wrap their
heads around but think of it this way
there is a population of the total
number of bankers in the world and there
is a population of the total number of
feminists in the world
some bankers are feminists but not all
and some feminists are bankers but not
all
therefore the total number of bankers
who are feminists is smaller than the
total number of bankers in the world so
believe it or not the details of linda's
bio are absolutely irrelevant
simply because the number of them is
greater it is statistically more likely
that linda is a banker than it is that
linda is both a banker and a feminist
weird tangent right so why am i bringing
it up because our assumption that other
flow artists must share our values and
ethics utilizes the same cognitive bias
somebody being a flow artist does not
necessarily mean they're more likely to
share your particular ethics values or
worldview yeah i kind of tricked you on
this one it's not actually a reason to
date within the flow community
mainly i'm bringing it up because it's a
reason that i think a lot of people
would offer up for dating in the flow
community but it's also one that they
might not realize is flawed incidentally
if you're interested i first read about
the linda problem in this really
fascinating book called thinking fast
and slow by daniel kahneman it's a
summary of 50 years worth of research he
did as a behavioral psychologist and
this is just one of many findings he
made that make your brain go ouch i'll
link to it in the description highly
recommended okay so now that i've gone
on this weird tangent about behavioral
psychology because i can let's talk
explicitly about some reasons why you
might not want to date in the flow arts
community first up it really has to be
said that shared hobbies do not equal
shared interests and that shared
interests do not always equal
compatibility there's something to be
said here not just for the what that
people do
but why they do it the why can
frequently be a bigger element of
compatibility than is immediately
obvious and tends to tell you a lot more
about who the person is than just the
what because what we do is so incredibly
niche it's easy to lose sight of the why
because the what is so important to us
but it's a really important facet of
compatibility and should not be ignored
and there's a lot more that goes into
relationships than just having shared
activities or interests how does your
partner or partners navigate conflict
how do they handle money what are their
life goals
just because you both flow doesn't mean
you'll be on the same page for all these
questions granted this is a risk for
dating in general so how about one more
specific to dating in the scene itself
the one that i've discovered the hard
way myself multiple times and i am sure
i'm not the only one is this
it can feel awesome dating somebody in
the flow world for all of the reasons i
listed above but when those
relationships end
they can make a space that has felt very
welcoming and comfortable now feel
incredibly uncomfortable or even unsafe
now i'm sure a lot of you out there are
still friends with your exes and power
to you but when a relationship ends
there are definitely complicated
feelings to work through and that can
make it difficult to be in the same
spaces that your ex is
it's not a bad idea to consider what it
might be like if you split up with a
fellow flow artist and you no longer
felt like you could go to your local
spin jam because of it now this by no
means is guaranteed but it is a risk and
it's literally happened to me every
single time i've dated another flow
artist
so do keep it in mind because the odds
of it happening are not zero and it can
have a really catastrophic impact on
your connection with your community next
up the elephant in the room
we are a subculture that draws together
lots of people that have a deep craving
to be seen and frequently are not great
at setting boundaries this means we also
tend to attract no shortage of harmful
actors that thrive in conditions such as
this i know no shortage of people who've
dated in the flow world and left it
because of abusers narcissists and
people who have a tenuous grasp on
consent or even that just haven't done
much work evaluating their relationship
habits we frequently like to think of
ourselves as being more enlightened than
a cohort of non-flow people but
honestly what i've seen happen way more
often is that people excuse themselves
by virtue of hanging out in
counterculture spaces from actually
engaging in any real self-reflection or
self-interrogation
this can have really catastrophic
impacts on their relationships whether
platonic romantic sexual or all of the
above let's also just be fully
transparent about at least one element
of this picture too
if you're a cishet guy in the flow arts
i can almost guarantee you've made a
calculation that by spending an enormous
amount of time improving your prop
spending skills you'll win not only the
respect of your peers but also the
admiration of potential lovers
and this time investment has likely come
at the expense of things like say
developing a real personality
confronting your privilege or
i don't know
going to therapy and unlearning your
toxic relationship habits i say this as
a guy who has fit this mold and is still
in the process of trying to right the
ship and
yeah
this is real
and frankly it's a thing to keep in mind
as you date cis hit men in the flow arts
they likely have not done a lot of work
on themselves
so proceed with caution guys go to
therapy
no getting blasted on psychedelics does
not count and finally because of the
unique makeup of this community it also
tends to be a haven for people who shirk
responsibility for their actions through
toxic positivity or spiritual bypassing
this is really a topic that should and
probably eventually will become its own
video on my channel
but especially during the quarantine it
became incredibly clear that there are a
lot of people in the flow world that are
deeply uncomfortable with having to
experience anything remotely resembling
a negative emotion
and will respond defensively if not
violently if confronted with one this
means that in dating there's a high
likelihood of being gaslit victim blamed
or deflected rather than one's partner
or partners engaging in accountability
for their actions there's been no
shortage of incidents i've seen wherein
somebody who has genuinely experienced
harms is ousted from their communities
for trying to air them because they're
harshing the vibe or bringing everybody
else down
being told anger is toxic
positive vibes only
or forgiving them will set you free are
just a couple of the many ways people
get gas lit by communities that thrive
on this kind of toxic positivity and in
the case of both toxic positivity and
spiritual bypassing
there's also a dimension wherein people
excuse themselves from doing their
shadow work from acknowledging their
anger their resentments their jealousies
rather than making those emotions
disappear they tend to explode out in an
unpredictable manner or worse get
projected onto those around them word to
the wise if somebody seems pretter
naturally cheerful happy or at peace
there might be something going on in
that story that they might not want you
to see
and when you do
it's a good question as to how they're
going to react to your seeing it okay so
as you can tell
i'm a little pessimistic about dating in
the flow world right now does that mean
that you shouldn't do it no absolutely
not i've been around long enough that
i've gotten my heart broken in a whole
bunch of different ways but
you can't find love or partnership if
you don't take chances you have to try
out different ways of finding it it's
hard enough to find love and
companionship as it is
none of us should look to that search in
such a way that we cut ourselves off
completely from one potential way of
finding those things
but
we should be cautious and sober in our
assessments of dating within the
community i know people who've had a lot
of heartbreak dating other flow artists
and i know people who've found long
lasting love and amazing partnerships in
it
both are possible and all of us should
keep that in mind as we explore
be safe out there this video would not
be possible if not for the wonderful
support of all of these amazing people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
helped make this video and all the
videos on my channel possible thank you
one and all for your support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signup you can do that
at the link in the description or the
card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and help me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
if you'd like to check out other videos
i've done on flow arts culture i'll
leave a link to a playlist of them down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you are watching this video on
youtube
the youtube algorithm also thinks you'll
like this top video based upon your
viewing habits too so you might want to
give that a look as well
thank you so much for watching make sure
to get outside and flow today and i'll
see you with a new video on wednesday
peace